[Music]
you must be truly desperate to come to
me for help if we do nothing they will
destroy us
that was for New York
will not ease your pain
I am Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for Wired we all know that big tentpole
pictures pivot on visual effects and
most people know that previous is used
to effectively pre make the film so that
scenes can be timed and worked out by
the director such as Thor's the dark
world Alan Taylor here are some
exclusive shots of that previous created
for the dark world by third floor in
London and LA not only as the previous
looking better and better these days but
companies like the third floor will also
provide post biz so it's so much quality
in particular control you might think
that the whole film is shot on blue
screen and just rendered in the computer
so it's a little bit surprising to see
just how much practical special effects
were used in a film like Thor hydraulic
rams concrete blocks then yep that's a
real concrete truck
and also to see how far they traveled to
film on alien-looking
realistic Icelandic locations yeah a lot
of the work we've been doing on for two
has been to try and ground it and to
sort of even though we're travelling
nine realms and in the universe to never
depart from it feeling real and you know
it's very important for me to shoot in
location and in Iceland to actually go
to the world where that almost of came
from and and try and get that like I
said the later imagery in the comics
into them Thor still has an awful lot of
fully digital shots but the actors were
also able to do a lot of their own
stunts because of the detailed planning
plus the great onset practical effects
team the director could basically film
extremely complex shots without
resorting to just filming two guys in a
giant blue box on a soundstage in
hollywood somewhere well at least most
of the time
I think you miss a column shut up
look why don't you let me take over I'm
clearly the best pilot is that right but
out of the two of us which one can
actually fly
don't forget to subscribe for more
behind the scenes action
I might see more for wide